-So, now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"ruin a movie with one word"
responses from you guys.
This first one is from
@hrreed1298.
She says,
"Weekend at Bernie Sanders."
This one is from @annielifeson
She says, "Iron Deficient Man.
-Oh.
-See?
-One A Day.
-Ruining -- Yeah.
One A Day.
This one's from @askingsatan
-Ooh!
Satan?
-Askingsatan.
-Oh, okay.
-He says "Indiana Jones and th
Shirley Temple of Doom."
-Oh. Two more.
-This one is from @brigaz85.
He says, "How to Lose
a Guy Fieri in 10 Days."
-Bang!
-This one is from @Jackyboy223
He says, "Breakfast Burrit
at Tiffany's."
Oh, there you go.
That's a different movie.
This one's from @badmovieman
-Oh!
-Wow.
This is right up his alley
It's probably the best day
of his life.
Badmovieman.
He says
"Pile-driving Miss Daisy."
-Ow! Wow!
Eh, family show.
-Alright. Come on.
♪♪♪♪
-Daisy.
-This one is...
[ Laughter ]
-Got to go make water.
-This is from @theswamprat
-Swamprat?
-He says "Charlie Sheen
and the Chocolate Factory.
That's a
totally different movie.
-Winning!
-This one is from @jpappone.
He says,
"Pirates of the Caribbean:
Dead Man's Chest Hair."
This one is from @Nickburesh
Wow. These are
interesting names.
He says "Harry Potter and th
Sorcerer's Kidney Stone."
-Oh. You shall not pass.
[ Laughter ]
"Lord of the Rings," but..
-I got you.
[ Applause ]
-Same thing.
-This one's from
@Joeydestefano5.
He says "Apocalypse Now-ish.
Now-ish. Sure.
This is from @artbypemphoto.
He says, "Who's Afraid of
Virginia Wolf Blitzer?"
This one from @Bethinmaine2020
She says "Cats."
-Oh, snap!
Oh! Oh!
Oh, no, you did not!
Wow! Wow!
She went there.
"Cats."
-Wow.
-Wow. Meow!
-Bing-bong-bong-boing!
-Ruin a movie with one word.
-Wow. "Cats."
-This one is from @Chriseckst.
He says "Planet of the Vapes."
You damn dirty vapes.
This last one is from
@megannails.
She says
"Lady and the Tramp Stamp.
There you have it.
Those are our hashtags.
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags